what is up everybody on today's show
we're going to learn how to design
websites in three easy steps
it could be done I don't know but Ron
Seagal is the man who's going to show us
how to do this you may know him from his
amazing YouTube channel called flux Ron
Segal welcome back to the show up graded
okay nice trying to pimp up my live
stream and set up your gonna outdo us
right now so the game is on okay so
without further ado let's just get right
into it web design graphic designers why
do you need to do it are you leaving
money on the table when you're not doing
the web design Ron take it away all
right so I've been talking with so many
designers later lately like even
freelance designers but both agencies
especially you know graphic designers
that are doing branding and in all types
of design and a lot of them I found out
are not designing websites which is just
like so weird yeah yeah it's like
imagine that you're you're going into a
restaurant then you ask the desert and
then they're like oh go to a restaurant
across the street it just doesn't make
any sense I mean everybody you know
every client entrepreneur business owner
who comes to you and needs to read and
obviously the next phase he's gonna need
a website it just doesn't make any sense
not to offer website as a designer
mm-hmm and I just realized just from
talking to other designers that a lot of
them just find it intimidating they
think it's so complicated with
everything that apt to take they hear
all these like crazy terms like UX and
you are and they're just like blown away
at how complicated it is and so I'm here
to share with you like how to think
about this it seemed really really
simple I want more designers to build a
website because here's the thing you
know everybody's now talking about UX
and UI and it's all like the rage but an
in product design you know how to design
whatever apps and dashboards but when
you think about it like there's so many
like there's few companies that need
product like digital product design
and whatever dashboards apps type of
thing right so it's kind of like a
pyramid because every business in the
world ends up meeting just a website so
there's just like crazy demand to it and
nobody talks about this word or teaches
this and so Matthew I was talking to
Matthew and he kind of challenged me he
was like can you put into and kind of
cover like five to ten steps on how
designers can get started about this and
I was like thinking about this and I was
like okay let me do it Wow where were
you and I started designing ran three
steps that's that's how the awesome yeah
that's it's it's kind of like let's go
through it I've prepared two
presentations so let's let's let's get
into it
you
are you saying go again hold on yes
what's wrong forgot to add audio on that
one okay hold on take it back to the
beginning of this what is web design
what what yes there we go okay go ahead
all right
so basically what is Web Design right so
basically it's content there's some text
there's some some thing like a story
that you want to convey there is
creative direction which is how you
visually present this how do you make it
appealing how do you make it pretty and
then there's technology like how is it
implemented into a website like how is
this literally built and this is
basically web design and but I actually
think like if you think about this I
actually think this is true for every
design because if if you take anything
like let's think about package design so
if you're you know I've seen your show
right now you're doing like packaging
for beer so obviously there's content
there's need to be whatever ingredients
the name of the company what's inside
there's the design of it how does that
look and there's the technology right it
needs to be printed in a certain way or
you have kind of technological
constraints right if you're doing book
design then it's going to need to be
printed on paper on a certain size from
certain material so in every design that
we implement in the world there is
technology involved and it's just the
web is just a different technology so
basically I think this is the framework
to think about any design but if you go
through these steps which I'll try to
break down to you right now
basically you'll be able to figure out
how to build websites relatively easy I
think please get started
mm-hmm so let's go through them like one
by one basically it's it's three steps
so first one is content right so
basically how these are some questions
that we need to ask ourselves when we
get like a website project so first one
is what is the goal what are we trying
to do and this is very similar to what
you cover in you know discovery sessions
or strategy session whatever you want to
call this this is also super true for
any website project you need to know who
are you doing this for who is the
customer
why are we even doing this and for a
website there can be all types of you
know things that you might
wanna achieve or you're applying such as
you know getting more lead or selling
something actually on the website or
educating people or getting engagement
and you need to understand this because
if you don't understand this you don't
know what call-to-action to put in now
that's it's I think so many people don't
understand this I've been going through
a lot of you know designers portfolios
which are basically websites and there's
simply no call to action it's like they
didn't even think what I'm trying to
accomplish with this website obviously
they're trying to get clients to call
them but they didn't even make it easier
on me a big like putting their you know
a big call-to-action contact me or
here's my idea so you need to wait up
first understand what are you trying to
do here like what's the call to action
what are we trying to accomplish with
this website now that you have this you
can ask yourself the question alright so
what's the story here
right so most people leave websites like
most when I say most I mean more than
85% leave every website below in less
than 15 seconds this is kind of like
most people don't understand this but if
you ever opened up any analytics you'll
be blown away to understand that most
people left your website in less than 15
seconds
so that you really need you be very very
clear and answer the question within
less than 15 minutes you have to answer
the question what is this website who's
this website what are they doing and for
me if you don't answer this really
quickly people are going to leave you
need what is the story how do I answer
these questions now some helpful
frameworks to tell stories couple that I
use is first one is called story brand
which is a book that you can get
basically it breaks down how every story
in the world works so it's something
like there's a hero they have a problem
they need kind of a guide that guide
gives them a plan and then you know they
go through the process and then they
solve the problem and this framework
actually explains that this is how most
you can build them and story for aim
work and that really helps you create a
story for your own website
website that's really really simple
another popular framework is the why how
what that was popularized by simon Sinek
I think he's called which is basically
answering like why this company exists
and how are you doing what you're doing
and we actually so these are frameworks
to kind of understand what is the story
that you're trying to say and that story
helps you together with your client or
with a Content writer to write write the
content write the story of this website
and again that can be applied to all
pages that it's a long story
every story can be very long told like
in in a very long form and a very short
form so this story has to you know work
within 15 seconds first 15 second you
need to get snip it out of that story
and then very long form so you know
let's say star wars right I can say it
very shortly like a guy his cousin's got
killed he met the Jedi he destroys the
evil forces right I told that in like 10
seconds and also you can watch
three-hour movie about this when you
have kind of a story you can stretch it
and expand or tell there's four three
now one thing about this is that words
are important I mean copywriting is
important I know that we read designers
are very much like to focus on the
visuals but when it comes to the web and
in general I think in advertising in
anything words are very important so you
need to learn how to tell the stories
both visually but also in the words and
I personally think that designers can
really benefit from learning how to
write also in sides doing the actual dis
so now now you have the story basically
now you need to structure it right now
in the web you know you tell stories
very similar to how you tell stories in
other formats right so in a book you
tell the story every page is the next
step in the story so you have page 1
then you have page 2 page 3 and that's
how you you structure the story if
you're doing the presentation then you
have obviously slide one two three when
it comes to website you basically have
sections right so you have the top
second then you scroll down you get to
the second section you scroll up so
basic
a page is basically like turning a page
and that's how you tell the story so you
tell the story section after section and
you can think about different pages in
the website like different chapters in
the book so that's how you need to
basically structure the content on a
page and one thing I want to say about
structuring the content we designers
won't we love to be creative and we love
to innovate and that's good sometimes
but sometimes it's not very useful and
when it comes to the web you know people
we ever and every one of us is using
website and browsing website all day
long so we know how that works and we
have certain expectations of how things
should work near the designer and you're
trying to read the wheel sometimes it
just creates more convenient and helpful
though you need to basically understand
like what what are the best practices
and how things work and there is a great
book that called don't make me think
that basically kind of gives you kind of
pointers about what you should or she
but you need to understand basically the
the medium in which you're working on so
that was basically step one and step one
as I said is dealing with the content
and the outcome of this step is you need
to have something that's like wireframes
now you you get started with you can see
the image of Bob kind of like what's
called low fidelity wireframes which
basically kind of depicts the structure
of the website so we're gonna have a
page about this and a page about this
and it's going to have this in that
content that helps you kind of you know
facilitate the discussion where your
clients are about is are we going in the
right direction and then you create like
more high fidelity wireframes which is
basically just kind of like a black and
white kind of like the content inside
but you don't put colors in it
you don't put visuals in it you just
want to see that the content is
structure the right way and you don't
use colors because you don't want them
to talk about design you just want them
to approve and see that the content is
accurate so you use this this is
basically a tool to to collaborate and
get approval these wireframes
right alright Rhonda wanted to jump in
there on the image there at the top he
also had what do you call that the
sitemap right on the job right yeah so
yeah you can call it a sitemap something
like or flowchart or whatever but this
is basically just means it's kind of a
high-level look at or the website right
um you basically would have that also on
the on the one below which is just like
a higher fidelity one which also
includes kind of like the real text hmm
and by the way when I do this I actually
write the text myself I'm not a
copywriter not even a native English but
I've put something there to try to help
them tell the story and when there's
something on the table even if it's
crappy it's it's good to get feedback so
I put the first version and it really
helps them to iterate on it and improve
on it rewrite it I think it's much much
better than just I see some designers
are doing kind of using like lorem ipsum
which really I can't really understand
what you're trying to do here with the
story and even you when you later on
you're gonna meet to create visuals here
how are you gonna know what to visualize
if there's no text right so I suggest
you get down to real actual text that
tells the story again it doesn't have to
be final final but you should you should
really try to put this in at this point
right okay you guys ready to move to the
next step we are yes thank you alright
okay so step number two how do we
actually design this how do we make this
look great so I get started by asking
the question like what is the best let's
call this art vehicle to reach our goal
right and this is pretty much similar to
what you guys are doing with the style
scapes basically I want to I want to
show the client different approaches to
things that might work and try to see
you together with them again it's a
discussion what might be the best fit
for their goal now I think that it's
very important to show many different
styles and I think a lot of designers
are opting to what they would call my
style which is basically what they know
what to do and that's not not
necessarily the best thing to solve the
clients you know to help the client
reach his goals and to best communicate
so I try to show everything even stuff
that I don't know how to do myself you
know illustration 3d photography
topographic whatever and I use a website
called lappa ninja which is basically
just a collection of a lot of landing
pages and it's really always updated so
I always go there collect reference I
like throw them into maybe you know
folders like 3d illustration and total
feel whatever to collect references and
then we use this kind of as a discussion
to where where we want to go so that's
that's basically the first thing now
based on the decision that we make here
I usually collaborate with other
creatives now and this is a photo of
redeem Olynyk he's an awesome art
director from London which I just really
recently collaborated with because
honestly you know you can't master all
every possible style right you can't do
it all yourself and so to really make
get the best results for your clients
you need to be able need to have kind of
a network and and you need to have
friends or people that you work with
that are very good at specific things
that you you want to collaborate with so
you might call it subcontractors or
whatever or flu dancers but basically
for me it's basically a network with
friends that I know that every one of
them is good with something else and we
work together on project depending what
is the best thing for the client and
again I don't try to do everything
myself because that's not necessarily
going to be the best thing for the
client all right the next step is
talking about typography and grid and
kind of stuff like that now on the image
on the right is a Google search when I
write free UIKit there's just
and tons of actually really great stuff
there and I kind of look at it as kind
of like an open source for designers so
open source if you don't know kind of in
the development world there's there's a
lot of project which is called open
source which means that people put them
out there for other people to take them
and reuse them as kind of a starter
point for their own project
and designers are starting to get into
that with like it's so you can find
really for whatever software you use you
can find really really great UI kits
which are basically a starting point
they already set the typography with you
know different sizes in a way that makes
sense that free to the grid for you now
you're gonna take this you're probably
not gonna use it as is right you're
gonna change to your own typeface for
the project so you're gonna need to make
a little bit of adjustments to the sizes
and to the grid and everything but it's
a great starting point and I I think a
lot of designers are so overwhelmed by
trying to think about everything
themselves and you don't really need
that you can you can get started with
you know kind of a library that sets the
general the general structure and and
work on that you know use that a point
and just go from there I think that will
really simplify now next point on that
is there's something that's called
accessibility which basically means that
you know mm some people have
disabilities of all coins and like some
people don't see well some people don't
see color as well and we need to take
that into consideration when we're
designing so I'm not gonna cover
everything but I think there's a really
great post by by Pablo Stanley which is
called designing for accessibility is
not that hard and basically he covers
the key principles which he should go
through before you know you finalize
your design it's things like you need to
have enough contrast in your colors on
so that people can actually see what you
did there you know we designers we like
the subtle subtle gray font that turns
out that people age of 23 can't read um
so you know we need
take care of that so just you know read
this it's on pause it's pretty short and
you're gonna see it's not such a mess
but you need to think now the most
common question that I get all the time
is like what tool should I choose and
there is not so many tools for for
designing for screens or a sketch figma
xt studio and every day and people
obsess over this as if if they just got
the right tool now they're gonna have an
amazing website but honestly guys
they're all the same I mean you know oh
thanks sir it's just like tiny features
okay some you know but it doesn't matter
don't over think about this and all of
these tools are if you already know or
InDesign or those are much your tools
which are basically drawing up
rectangular Wow you're giving them
rounded corners you're throwing in
images and that's it like it's it's a no
brainer so just pick one whether it is
you know if you're on a go way you're
gonna get a text e for free or if you're
on whatever you choose one of them if
you want collaboration go with figma but
it doesn't really matter so don't get
stuck there on you can just move forward
with the design ready all right are you
ready for step three all right so
technology so I think it's really
important to understand the medium for
which you're designing for and what are
the capabilities I always think that you
know you can't really if you're a print
designer and you don't know the
difference between you know what's RGB
and CMYK you're gonna be really
disappointed I mean you use that shiny
green color and it's not gonna print
that way because hey you can't really
print RGB colors so you need to
understand what's possible so one thing
that you what you want to do and because
that is always developing with such a
fast pace you always want to stay
up-to-date and there's you can browse
websites like like awards or or code
drops or code ban which basically shows
you what are the latest kind of like
experiments or or cutting-edge
innovation that are possible for the web
and I know I've heard or I saw Ben's
tweet
Awards where he will dude those website
I'm so unpractical and it's true but you
don't have to design them like this but
you need to know that it's possible that
it's possible to create this animation
it's possible to do this effect because
you might want to use it at something so
you just know what's possible so just
educate yourself I was aiming by looking
what other people are doing now the
second thing is again as I talked about
you know the difference between RGB and
Ceylon cake you need to understand key
concept now let me super quickly go
through key concept of the web so
websites are built from HTML pages
that's basically the content right
well actually what we talked about in in
step 1 it's basically like the texts and
you know the how this is structured CSS
which stands for cascading style sheets
is basically styles and basically it's
very very similar to InDesign or for any
other design software you have a Spile
aim like big title and there's a
definition like ok a big title is always
black 37 pixels and this font so this is
basically the definition of how
everything on the HTML looks like that's
that's basically how the structure works
now the main difference between how
designers usually think about their
designs and how it's really implemented
on the web is that there's a mental
frame or mental concept I don't remember
how to say this but basically it's
called the box model and the box mark
like so when we designers use design
software to design and we're used to
layers right you have a stack of layers
and basically it means what's on the top
is on the top and what's at the bottom
is on the bottom right that's how it
stacked together but on the web things
are dynamic the sizes change and there's
relationships what actually happens is
that it's not something on top of
something it's actually a box within a
box within a box but everything that you
see on a page is actually a box that has
some properties but those CSS properties
that we talked about
like this box has a red background and
all the text in it are you know Green is
sort of fun and inside of it so this box
might be lets say a section inside of it
there might be another box which says
this is a button for example and so you
need to understand how this model works
so you can decide define you know the
spacing and how it react when the screen
size changes so that's kind of like a
different mental model but he said
you're so familiar with it really again
not that difficult but it's just a
different way of thinking that you need
to read now but basically the one of the
last things that you need to consider is
you know not everybody has the same
screen obviously you know mobile
everybody who's designed for mobile and
actually what you see on the right is
actually Facebook on what's called today
a dumb phone which is what a lot of
people in the world are actually using
no not like we take smartphones for
granted but it's not the case for
everybody but what I put this for here
is that you need to understand that you
know not everybody has the same screen
so if the color is the uniform yet
screen doesn't mean that everybody's
gonna see it that way not everybody has
the same internet speed so you need to
think of it that some people are gonna
be on older browsers which might not
support everything so you have a little
bit of considerations to do and again it
really depends on who are you designing
for who your clients customers are so
that that's kind of things that you
should think and obviously be sure to
test it on relevant devices before
you're going live so basically the last
thing now that you have the the design
ready is now you need to think about
what's the next step like how do I take
this beautiful design that I did how do
I get this to to a live website and
basically you have a few options to do
with that um so the first one and I've
been spending a lot of time about
quarter a lot of my career I've used to
outsource my work to developers I used
to send the design and they would design
it they would develop it each one of
these options obviously has pros and
cons so
when you're when you're outsourcing to a
developer one of the cons is you don't
have to do it yourself right that's
something good con of this is that first
of all it costs a lot of money so
sometimes it's up to like 50 percent of
the cost of the website sometimes even
more just go through the developer or
building the website right and also
communication like explaining to them no
no this is not what I meant
this is not how I want things to animate
this is this takes you a lot of which
again time time is money is the second
one is that you can do it yourself and
there's a lot of possibilities today
there's tools like wakes and Squarespace
there's plug-ins for WordPress the
elementary is one of them there's
another one that's full DV and those
solutions the good thing about them is
that they allow you to do it yourself so
you don't have to depend on a developer
to do them they're also relatively I
would say he who learn so it kind of
like I would say for dummies but a lot
of them were actually designed not for
designers they were actually designed
for clients to do them to do the work
themselves so that you don't have to
know about anything now the problem with
those solutions is that you're kind of
limited because you're working within
templates so basically they they kind of
designed more or less components for you
and you have to work within them so if
that fits your design that's good and
well but if that's not what you wanted
to achieve then you're kind of in a
problem here I'm kind of limiting that
the third option which is obviously my
favorite or not obviously but it is my
favorite is web flow which is basically
a tool a development tool that was build
for designers so you actually do the
development yourself without writing
code now the good thing about that is
first of all you don't have to depend on
the developer so you don't have to pay
somebody else and usually the time that
it would just take you to communicate is
the time that you're actually getting
the site done so it helps you making
money you're going to charge for the
development and you save up time the con
of this or why this is hard for a lot of
designers is that there's a learning
curve here and
takes time to learn this because you
need to understand all those mental
models that I've mentioned earlier you
need to learn to think like a developer
to understand how to do it yourself and
wait efficiently so that's kind of like
why it's hard for for some designers but
obviously I'm I'm a very bit a big
advocate for them I've been working with
them for like almost four years now it's
literally changed my my freelance career
so I'm a big fan of this option well
whatever you choose I think the most
important thing is you just get started
because don't leave money on the table
just like and as I said before there's
just like every business in the world
meets the website every business in the
world meet their website updated
consistently so that's a good
opportunity to do interesting work to
detain or work on to bring a lot of
value to your clients
so yeah just just get started hey that
was fantastic
yes I felt like a little value oh no it
was and just as a little personal story
because you guys might think okay so
we're so Ron loves clothes of course and
all roads lead to web flow but Ben burns
leading our digital web team and the
marketing team has evaluated many
different options and we now have fallen
in love with web flow and we've used
well flowed to develop sites for for
Hamilton brewery yeah yeah so that ties
into building a brand the series so
people who are fans of that who have
gone to their web site that's a web flow
site right and the future site is going
to be a web flow site so this is like
exciting things and we're hearing from
the people who are using it there is a
learning curve but it's not steep it's
not horrible it's a couple of weeks
worth of work to figure it out then
there are at least three members of our
team who are already using web flow who
aren't even say classically trained as
web designers right it's pretty
fantastic tool they don't have any
coding backgrounds they're just visual
designers visual designers and doing the
coding work and I do want to share some
of the pain points before we open it up
to questions so I'm prompting Matthew to
get ready with the questions for you Ron
from people who are watching and tuning
in live saying hello to everybody
is that I feel the pain because when I
was getting started and doing web design
I didn't know half of what you know now
but I would hand it off the developer
and the pain points that you talk about
a really true I want to spend a moment
here to talk about that weight and and
this probably one of the reasons why
some designers don't get into web design
because we can design it we can think
through the problem but then there's
this technology gap and then we
outsource it and then there's all this
frustration like I don't know if I'm
over selling or under selling something
if I'm being overcharged or under charge
I just don't know I have no control over
it and this very thing did happen to us
we outsource our coding almost all of it
the development and some developers were
really slow and getting back to us and
it was creating a some tension between
us
and the and and the client because the
at this point it was in the hands of
somebody else and we couldn't make it go
faster we couldn't make it more high
fidelity or we couldn't control all
those things and I'm not saying I'm a
control freak cuz I would love to just
give to other people but they're not
mind reader's there's a gap there and so
there's definite pain so and honestly
I've been talking with I have a few
friends who own agencies and big
agencies here in Israel and so it
actually splits into people who have
totally given up on this because of this
and two people who are doing this but
they're actually losing money
yeah so they're like I'm gonna I'm gonna
do their website just because it's part
of what their the contract is if I'm if
I want to get this branding and I'm
gonna make the money back on the
branding but actually if you kind of
like calculate the money on the web
design project they lost money on that
project and you know they're losing
money on it just to get the clients but
it's they're losing money and and and
basically I've helped a few agencies
turn things around by you know training
their their teams with left flow and
helping them do it in-house and it came
back in from being a profit Center
mm-hmm
okay let's jump to the questions I
there's a lot there's a very active chat
going on right now
a hard time keeping up so Matthew what
kind of questions should we elevate to
the top yeah I think one big one that is
because in our audience we have
designers and some people who are really
deep into web design and development Ron
do you have a stance on what something
like web flow is really good for like
the types of sites that it's really good
for versus things it might not be good
for okay so I think like the ideal use
case at least for me is what I think
it's being called as a marketing website
so a company has a website that tells
about the company whether whether it is
you know a tech company or a restaurant
or whatever every business the kind of
the business website I think that's the
ideal use case obviously there's you
know there's blogging platform on it so
you can create content websites on it
there's now ecommerce so you can Freight
ecommerce website on and I think that
the core strength is is for basically
business websites now what I don't think
it's ideal for is a lot of people think
this is a lot of people confuse actually
web apps and web sites so let's take an
example like when you book flights
online mm-hmm you feel like you're
browsing a website you're actually using
an app you're doing you're performing
searches you're you're you have a
booking system you're maybe iterated
with few different websites to pull data
from you're actually using an app and so
a lot of people are trying to use web
flow to build apps and it's not you can
make it do it you can hack it your way
through but it's not ideal people who
are trying to go and like maybe
subscription websites or portals where
you have users and passwords and user
management all that type stuff you can
do that by integrating third-party
services but if that's not like the the
ideal use case I would say hmm okay yeah
that's I have a question for you why do
you say
that the ideal website to build is a
marketing site because it has it has
almost little logic to it no coming back
what's called back-end you know in
development where you need to have the
server performs you know whatever
calculations manage database like that
again you can include use the CMS which
is content management system but which
which is basically databases but it's
it's basically website that is most of
its content and then this content is
designed using you know front-end
development the back end is pretty lean
let's say and then the core use of that
is what I call marketing website but
that's basically I would say like 80 to
90 percent of the websites on earth you
know right mm-hmm
I see what you're saying and you have
some you have several years of
experience designing and then now also
building websites just for us to kind of
get a sense of budgets when we say we're
leaving money on the table by not
offering our clients to design and build
their website
what kind of budget range ranges can we
expect for these marketing sites that
you're talking about so obviously
obviously you you know that you budget
really depends on who the client is but
just like the recent example of over the
website that I did and I did a king
study on this on a website that was
$25,000 of a website all right so and I
did as I've mentioned I've collaborated
with really artists to give an animation
for me so that's not all profit but most
of it here and this is yeah yeah so but
that's the type of clients that I work
with I work with tech companies so that
that's that's a budget that's the range
of budgets that I work with I can tell
you that most of my students right so I
have
now 1,000 students in my web flow
masterclass course mm-hmm I would say
from what I hear and talk to people that
the budgets the typical average budget
ranges between maybe five to ten
thousand dollars of what you know I see
my students are doing yeah
and for a site let's just say ten
thousand so we can keep the numbers
around here
per site that's ten thousand dollars how
much of that would you have had to spend
having a developer make you think at
least fifty percent
okay these five at least yeah okay again
I just I just I just had lunch with with
the you know with the agency on her
friend that I had like a couple of weeks
ago and he told me like and they're
they're not working with web flow but
specifically on this one big website
that they had the the client insisted
and after they build it with a flow it
will be translated to WordPress and he
told me that the developer charged
$20,000 for just translate they already
build the front-end in web flow and they
exported the code for them so just
plugging that code into WordPress cost
them $20,000 to me that's like craziness
but oh well
Rhonda there was a question that had
come up here in the chat and this is
from Fran Giotto chick and he asked I'm
scared that the man for a web design
might go down just with all of these
tools making it easier and easier
what does that trend look like to you do
you feel like Web Design is actually
growing in terms of needs for clients or
is it shrinking because it's getting
saturated okay so what am I feeling
about this is it's true basically for a
lot of the design world it's not only
website it's true for branding and for
other in marketing design as well
I would say that if there was a pyramid
let's say of high level designers
mid-level designers and level designers
my feeling is that the middle is getting
squeezed out by its new technological
tools right so now clients can design
websites or buy a template they can also
go to a website like your brand or
whatever and have the logo made in like
15 seconds from $100 so those are and my
feeling is that these tools are hurting
the middle of the market or yeah the
middle of the market but it so there
will always be demand at the top right
there will always be people who need
premium brand premium websites you know
premium design in general right but the
truth is that the the majority of the
people in the world are bad business
sense that brands bad whatever
everything so I feel like there's more
opportunities at the top now but some of
them are dropping to at the bottom
that's true and I think that you as a
designer have to make the move to make
sure that you're going up and you're not
you can't stay in the middle anymore
that's what I think you have to start
moving upwards and bring more value and
have to be premium because you can't be
average anymore
nobody needs average you can get average
for 50 dollars now you know average like
a $50 is very very good in terms of it
it's good its average good right yeah so
you you have to be you have to be you
have to bring strategic value I think
and it's it's true for branding it's
true for for web design and that's why a
lot of the value is not only in the
execution it's a lot in the initial
stages of the strategy and what are you
going to do with the website and what
are we even going to put there
how are we going to structure this and
hey let's and when you are designing
it's not just hey let's grab some tender
stock photos let's do something creative
there we go illustrate or we go do
something 3d or we go do a creative
photo shoot but you need to do something
that's worth standing out you know
mm-hmm so I have a question for you
because we've been following what you've
been doing for some time now and you
said that you have a thousand students
in your web flow master class and and
that primarily is a class to teach you
how to use web flow how to make money
off of it how to connect it to design
are you going to start teaching people
how to design the front part and connect
it to the technology part cuz you said
there's three parts right content
basically design and technology so as
far as I understand the web flow master
class is the technology component are
you developing something to handle the
second part the design because that's
where a lot of our community is coming
from I'm sorry just neck next I want to
say next months but it turns out that
next months is next week right so next
week I'm starting work on my new my new
course which would be about web design
in general which is actually going to be
I think it's going to be one two three
because web flow is only part of the
execution and I'm teaching people how to
use web flow but I'm not teaching them
how to think about interactions how to
think about what to do with the
technology so I think that a new course
I'm aiming to cover one two three yeah
and basically I'm doing that because
that like that's one of the most common
thing that I heard for I hear from my
students they're like yes now I can
build websites but now I want to be able
better websites because I also want to
move up to that premium premium place
where I can charge $10,000 plus for a
website and I want to know how to bring
that value that unique value mm-hmm
fantastic so do we get a sneak peak or
at least the outline of what it is that
you're going to be teaching in this
design class I think that was like the
like when I created that presentation
I was like I think this is a good
framework to think about the course
right huh honestly I again I always
start next week but so I didn't have
time to spend on thinking about the
structure yet but when I was preparing
for this talk I kind of came up with
this structure and I think it makes
sense to think about it this way
obviously there's things like you know
how to manage the client relationship
and how to manage the project and all
sorts of stuff that we didn't cover
today probably we all cover but I think
when it comes to the design itself I
think that's what you need to understand
you know how to create good content and
structure it correctly in in a useful
and beautiful way and then you need to
know how to design it visually to make
it beautiful
you yeah and then think about how your
are you going to develop it yeah I want
to address a comment from one of our I
think longtime in in very loyal
followers or our subscribers so Channel
Tony Alves he says I love Ron but
because there's always a but in the I
love statement I love Ron but I'm a
developer and I'm feeling some bad vibes
with this discussion
do you agree about the apps but there
are better ways and options for making
sites now let's address this comment and
I'm gonna take a stab at it first
Ron is really speaking to designers not
developers and he already told you guys
that web flow is a tool specifically
built for designers to cross that
digital divide the coding divide if you
will to help you kind of bridge that gap
and it may be threatening to some
developers like they don't need them
anymore that will also cause developers
to to level up and go up and not give
average but I think for people like Tony
who want deeper stuff don't worry about
it this is not a discussion or a talk
that's designed for you per se you want
to add to that run yeah so a few weeks
ago I was I actually I went to Kiev
Ukraine to do a team training for an
agency to teach their designers how to
use web flow and basically this agency
does a lot of landing pages and stuff
like that and right now their processes
they would design it and then it would
take four days from
that when they finish the design to when
they'll they'll put it live by working
with developers and I told him guys you
can do it in one hour and so they
brought me there and I was there
training the designers but the front-end
developers were in the room oh well and
to kind of see what what this is and and
everything now I could see on their eyes
and in their questions that they are are
scared and being scared sometimes lead
to being angry yeah but I think
basically you said it and I said it even
earlier right
these tools are going to make average
not necessary and when it comes to web
site the the front-end development 85 I
would say to 90 percent of the web sites
on earth requires average capabilities
10% of them are requires unique
development that you cannot do with web
flow or that you have to using custom
code right like I would think that a
brand like Nike perhaps maybe just an
example that does custom crazy [ __ ] that
is you know you would see on an award
because it it is cutting edge and doing
some like stuff that you know web flow
might create a feature for that next
year but first
somebody needs to show that it's usable
before web poll is going to be a bad
feature so somebody's going to be at the
cutting edge of development and to be in
the cutting edge of development you need
custom development so if you're a
developer you do want to be in the
cutting edge of development in the upper
as I just like I said for designers
you're gonna be at the top premium there
you're gonna be in a really high value
unique work there is no use for you to
do the average look because if there is
if if there are developers listening so
there's you know something like
something that's called flexbox which is
kind of a layout property of CSS now do
to write that it would require like ten
lines to write how
want to position something and you can
do that in web flow with three clicks so
you can't beat me on that you can't
write the ten lines faster than I click
three buttons you just can't but there's
no use for you to do that right now I'm
not saying you don't need developers I'm
saying for a lot of things you don't
need developers you're saying ID you
don't need developers and then one
second later you're like what you don't
need a lot of things you don't need okay
and I've used developers for a lot of
web flow websites to extend capabilities
and to create something even web folk
can't do right but that would be simple
I was like I need this one tiny hack and
then they would solve it in an hour but
it's just when you need it you don't
always need it you don't just do things
because that's how you used to do things
like ten years ago yes yes yes so let me
let me let me channel my inner Yoda I'm
gonna channel my inner Yoda and say fear
leads to anger anger leads to dark side
okay so you guys that are afraid let's
look at this when desktop publishing was
invented as a viable solution for the
mass market it put a lot of typesetters
out of business right and when when the
laser printer was invented it put the
the dot matrix printer out of business
and the dot matrix printer put put out
put the Daisy wheel printer out of
business so there's a jump and every
time there's a technology push you got
to just jump to the next thing Guy
Kawasaki calls it jumping the curve
that's how you innovate so technology
displaces people it's happening all the
time think about the things that you
don't have to do anymore because of
technological advances when was the last
time you went into the field and planted
your own food and harvested it when was
the last time you went into the field
and hunted for an animal to then have
protein to eat well technology is
displacing lots of things so I think we
just got to learn to go for it because
change is inevitable but progress is a
choice so you guys let's just get to it
let's get to it people if you're
watching
the future it's not called watching the
past it's called the future so let's
think about where we're going
that's it Jaden that's a cut down I want
to go back to the questions cuz there's
a couple that are posing yes sir
so I wanted to ask as we were just
talking about features like you said the
the flexbox neora asked a while ago
what about integrating animations and
then like can you talk to us about some
other like the fancy features that are
built into web flow that make it very
easy to make these gorgeous looking
sites so basically you could do well I
do I know I want to say you can do
everything but you can do if you're in
you know if you know what CSS animation
is which is basically animating the
properties so prop you know animating
position scale rotation all that stuff
that you can do really really fast and
natively so you can you can create those
animation very very fast
up until now one thing that is very very
common in recently it's called SVG
animation you know you might know that
when you're in a website and you see
these the illustration drawing
themselves you see the line drawing
themselves and something like that which
is basically just there's a vector or a
nose you know the the stroke is going
through it or something like that so
basically there is something that's
called Lodi it's a bit technical but
it's something that was developed by
Airbnb that basically allows you to
export animation from after-effects into
code if those are vector animations and
then you can use it to in a website to
animate you know the illustration and
that you that would to integrate that
into web flow it would require a little
bit of hacking it's possible but it
requires a little bit of hacking and
hitbox I don't know if I'm allowed to
say this but it's yesterday I got an
email from the guy said where's my
breaking news stuff
ah freaking honey I can't find it never
mind just do your thing that's gonna do
breaking news go ahead yeah anyway
anyway yeah it's there I I already have
the better of how you do this
integration now natively so I'm gonna
play with this next week I didn't
experiment but now it's about to be
super simple as well to integrate
Claudie animation which is something
that's really really a lot of people
were excited about mm-hm
yeah so that's going to be easy-peasy
there was a question here Matthew that
you can answer for us somebody was
asking about how long it took to develop
the Hamilton brewery site yeah - so we
had our intern do it we had a high level
designer do three days it took her three
days to build from scratch like from
scratch and she doesn't have any code
coding background so there you go three
days yeah exactly
yeah wintering yeah that's right and
we're gonna get more into that in the
series as you'll see but it's a it's
pretty interesting I mean that's how
easy it is it's like you said it's very
much like Photoshop so I'm just watching
our designers play with this I haven't
touched it myself but I watched them do
it it's like oh that's it you just click
click click and then things are
animating things have parallax and it's
beautiful it's gorgeous
mmm gosh dang okay so we're coming up on
an hour here on the show what kind of
things do we need to hit before we end
the show Matthew let's see uh I mean a
lot of these are like technical web flow
questions I just wanted to talk about
maybe some people have concerns about
the hosting on web flow yes like how do
you deal with clients and I know web
flows actually has thought a lot about
these things and how to address them so
maybe run if you want to quickly talk
about hosting because I from our
experience it's lightning fast yep
so I love hosting with web flow but I do
agree and I've had the experience as
well that some clients
don't want for several of reasons they
might not want to host with webflow some
of those reasons can be um they want to
post it on their servers might be I
don't know security might be they want
to connect it to some kind of a back-end
might be that they want to you know
whatever for several reasons right and
in this case in this case web flow and
allows you to export the code and then
you can do whatever you want with it I
usually try to discourage clients from
this but again at the end of the day
it's the clients position it's their
website and they get to make the
decision so either if they need to
export the export they need to set it
translate the web flow website to
something like WordPress that's also
possible so yeah but again the the
reasons why I usually try to tell me
that it's a good idea that it makes
future update and maintenance super
super fast seamless which usually save
the money you know the the content
management system which is how they
update the website and his like top
top-notch which is what a lot of clients
are frustrated it in with limits to
WordPress websites yes speed wise a lot
of clients are just you know they have
some kind of a hosting yet whatever
GoDaddy or something and web websites
are hosted on Amazon top of the line
with most expensive most fast
whatever servers so you know it's good
you know it's dependable so that's how I
usually explain it yeah and I wanted to
share our experience too like handing
off web flow sites to clients it's been
pretty fantastic to see that I think in
the past when we were using WordPress
sites it would take hours to train them
I was like here's the backend and if you
want to update this you go here and you
do this drop down and you click here and
it's like multiple steps to shows about
that intuitive it's not that intuitive
it's it's kind of wonky cuz we're always
hacking it to make it look good all
right use lots of plugins to make it
look good
versus webflow because it's like a
visual designer it's very easy for them
to just click on something update that
type and then it's done and it's it's
already published and and that's it it's
it's one click for them and it's been
pretty amazing to see that training
process shrink down so significantly for
our clients the handoff processes well
we read another comment here because
there's another developer in the group
unfortunately the name is so hard for me
to pronounce I think it's called El bit
tum mo but this person is saying I'm a
developer and I think it's great because
I know its limitations and what can be
done as an actual developer this is
exactly how you use tools you don't
fight it you use it and then you either
create custom code or you hack it or you
you push it beyond its initial
conception which I think that's the way
you do it mm-hmm all right what else
Matthew what else do we need to talk
about um I think a lot of those are the
the major ones I think Ron if people
want to continue learning web flow can
you talk to our audience about your
course because I think you have a very
unique positioning for your course and
maybe could you illuminate that for us
right okay so basically you know I used
web fold myself again from the initial
early bettah of web flow and so I I
started using it with relatively simple
and funny things expended but I always
thought you know if I could learn it
myself probably everybody can learn it
themselves and actually web flow
themselves have an amazing amazing you
know web flow University so they put up
a lot of videos and still I was getting
tons and tons of questions about how to
do things and how to work with clients
and how to take the process from start
to finish to actually building it and so
I think that when I built my course I
was more focused on the real process
that I use with clients and not just
because I think that a lot of the videos
that web flow are doing or very they're
great technical videos they're like how
to use a specific feature
but what I found out that most people
struggle with is how do you actually
think about this and how do you go from
start to finish from planning it to what
are the first two how do you hand it off
to a client how do you work with it how
do you do the training how do you how do
you explain the pros the cons how do you
deal with the hosting what happens you
know obviously web flow and teach you
how to convert it to WordPress because
it's you know against their religion
which is okay I have to deal with the
limitations of real-world designer that
actually works with it for client work
and have to deal with the limitations
that you know sometimes things are not
perfect sometimes you need to hack them
sometimes you need to do things that way
or there's there's you know a faster way
to do things or a more efficient way to
do things so I think that's what I tried
to to achieve with the course and from
from the comments and feedback that I
get from my students a lot of them have
seen the free videos but they just
wanted to shortcut you know they wanted
to to spend even a weekend and bam being
able to build their own website or
client website or take on a project and
and we have an amazing supportive
community that helps you solve problem
that shares trying to work that project
so it's it's it's been incredible hmm
yeah okay okay I want to tell you guys a
little personal story and then I think I
know how to wrap up the show today okay
here's the personal story my son comes
in to work with me from time to time
he's 12 years old and yesterday I told
him go clean up the stage and at the end
of the day he came home with me psyched
had I'm so tired I know why I'm so tired
it's like well you were up all day and
you were working and I was a little bit
of work he's like no dad so how long did
you take to clean up the stage he said
one hour so hard and I'm sweeping the
floor I'm disinfecting surfaces I'm
spraying for breezes I was instructed
and wiping down the walls it's a lot of
work for this little boy he was like it
was hot in there
had and I said well that's what you get
for doing manual labor because prior to
this time he's been thinking when he
comes of age and he's able to work he's
gonna go work at McDonald's cuz he
thinks it's gonna be easy
I said well working for your dad and
cleaning up the stage is nothing
compared to working for McDonald's
you're gonna be over the hot burner of
the probably the frying station or
something like that then he's like why
is everybody at the office using Webb
float and can I build a website using
webflow and I said yeah you can why
don't you watch the torus and learn how
to do it people are saying it's
relatively easy to do and you could
charge your friends how to do this and
in fact we know people who need websites
built that can probably do it for that
can probably afford like fifteen hundred
two thousand dollars that you can do as
a kid as a twelve-year-old kid you can
build a website for somebody because
they need this thing done your friends
need this people need this and he's like
Wow so yesterday I made five dollars
working for an hour sweating just
grinding away at it you say I can make
fifteen hundred dollars and he's like
but what if I'm not that good what if
I'm just not that excellent well okay
that's a problem if you're not that good
then you'll just suck and nobody will
hire you why even ask the kind of
question you have to be good so here's
what I think here's what I think let's
say you're a designer and you don't want
to do well flow and you're just really
reluctant but at least now you're gonna
start selling websites as part of the
services you provide you can team up
with another designer who's pretty good
at web flow and help you make this maybe
that's a bridge or you can learn it
yourself that's entirely up to you what
we try to do here at the future is we
try to teach people and share with them
as many options and avenues as we can
knowing that for some it won't work and
for some it'll be like what they needed
here today because they keep saying that
I needed to hear this today so you're
stuck if you're backed into the place
and you feel like selling the Lugg was
just not gonna be enough and you need to
do more but you're afraid of the
technology I encourage you just give it
a peek
take a look what I love about your
community run is that you talked a lot
about website and web design and how to
make money doing that and managing
projects and then there's our community
and the two communities come together to
make a beautiful child
call it getting started in web design in
three
easy steps and I love it you gave me a
really high-level overview of web design
and I learned some things today and I'm
an old dude and if I can learn something
this is good
I'm like really oh thanks everybody for
saying how young I look thank you very
much I love it thank you very much
so we want to encourage you guys that
are webflow curious for you to
experiment it's okay it's okay
you can dabble in it it's all okay and
if you wanted to take the class you can
tell like runs are really good teacher
he's very passionate and he backs his up
with real life real world experience
he's not some kind of hack he's not some
academic person who's like here's a good
theory he's actually done these things
and so you want to take it from him but
I just want to tell you take his class
but use our link user link below please
use our link and that's all that's all
we got man so Ron thank you very much
for coming on the show do we have any
last questions and give us a good body
all right everybody please help me thank
Ron Segal for coming on the show guys
[Music]